welcome to this video playing anti duck
from Australia international Massa
Andrew Brown yeah
never heard yeah well okay that really
thousands of I am so nowadays so can't
know them all okay we capture the
Russell evil the civilian and normally
white can just play there was some
conventional developing moves Bishop III
Queen d2 and maybe exchange the bishop
yeah do I play probably I do preventing
something to come to 2g fall okay let's
prepare a form so that at least I'm have
some idea here okay 95 okay well I don't
want to exchange that okay so G form
yeah yeah certainly why not oh why not
I'm slightly weakened here on the inside
maybe here or to g3 what's my idea here
anyway okay let's let's go here the idea
that I'm trying to place a five and
ninety four thirty six anticipating on
long cancels so here yeah you don't want
to go all the way back but rookie have
to this Bishop deform okay it's it's
clear that giving up the dark square
Bishop Ellis is problematic
I just just just go back the other
squares are really not making much sense
anyway if he castles long I've got Queen
a forum with Queen BH and yeah Queen B
eight and the the bishop hanging so I
don't think he can cancel long and I'm
also not sure if this check is really
helping him maybe
but after you five this bishop is nicely
placed but also a bit cut off from the
action
yeah I need to hmm or queen it for even
threatening the c6 move yeah baby yeah a
tricky position probably and worse my
king is insecure he's got H for H free
stuff like that but it's not that it's
not super clear I mean I have 94 to d6
this is also oh wait
if I do 94 there's also c3 threatened
shutting the bishop yeah I'm not sure
that this bishop default check really
was so great okay
but am i threatening e6 yeah he believed
me
okay need to do this here anyway was
this with the c3 idea and what is just
ignoring this young maybe okay I can
give it a check first and then play c3
I'm also attacking f7 so
oh maybe he wants to sacrifice but okay
I can I can take capture probably needs
to go Queen d7 to block the porter still
have c3 this is probably good for me so
c3
just just c3 how to proceed now maybe
they maybe just pushed the a pawn you
will play h3 this is not not easy
Queen g5 maybe it's not clear what Queen
g5 really accomplishes
okay it's h8 3 I will just take I'm
absolutely not sure that this is I can
give this chicken Queen age 3 maybe
mm-hmm may I'm 57 but it's not clear
that this is actually great yeah it's
very very tricky maybe I should have
gone 395 25 was an alternative to h4
just attacking the bishop and probably
it needs to retreat them I didn't see it
should be 5 check and then Queen h3 I
would have Queen f5 okay I have twin f5
forces this is good
yeah it's always a bit scary if you
don't have any porn cover jack yeah I'm
threatening Queen f5 over the sister
this is a cool Bishop g4 a bishop d4
with the double check and mate
hmm okay run for the hills
wow this is really dangerous so d7
should I go d7
the seven he probably maybe he moves the
King it cannot be so bad actually now
this one
he always needs to what
I don't see a mate it's it's not looking
like it shake made ready check check
time morning
yeah there's no threat at all I think
check check check check
check
I've got to check
black resigns this was very scary
oh maybe maybe you really had something
yeah this is this is a very critical
position here maybe the computer of
course is always very cool wants to go
rook a to e 1 and on h3 play would be F
2 dot computer this is probably - yeah
probably not good I mean I simply don't
have the time for fancy meals like a 4 a
5 now he breaks through yeah and this is
computer gives rook h3 now with a
distinct advantage this also now Bishop
h6 bar
yeah it is very very very dangerous King
f2 is probably the only move but not
difficult to find no a5 but that's
actually good okay but I hope ok this
Bishop h6 is a draw but this loses him
yeah this losses unfortunate like yeah I
can go to see one but I wasn't so sure
now guess wins wins as well
two queens is a bit much only need to
fit not Queen f3 not allow this maid
okay yeah thanks for watching